I'm Dr Amy Shah MD and specialist in
women's health today I'll be answering
your questions from Twitter this is
hormone support
[Music]
convojo asks what actually are hormones
and how can I remove all of them you
wouldn't want to remove your hormones
because then you would literally die
hormones are chemical Messengers that
regulate our mood our Attention our
growth our sexual activity our disease
risk our hormones make us who we are
hormones are part of the endocrine
system people get confused between the
nervous system and the endocrine system
but the endocrine system uses liquid
chemicals versus electrical impulses at
alapai asks can't sleep is it just
hormone or question mark hashtag
midnight tweet insomnia I think a lot of
us could have written this tweet because
there are multitude of hormones that are
involved in sleep but the main one you
might have heard of is called melatonin
the pineal gland in the brain produces
melatonin and that melatonin actually
binds to many different places in the
body including the brain to tell it to
get ready for bed melatonin secretion is
is very influenced by Blue Light by
stress and by the things that you eat or
drink like caffeine melatonin also can
be taken by supplement form but remember
most people are taking way too much
melatonin 10 milligrams of melatonin 20
milligrams of melatonin that is way too
much you don't want to suppress your
natural release of melatonin you want to
stick to like 0.5 milligrams to three
milligrams Max at Isabella Gomez asks
how come we don't really talk about how
hormones from birth control are the
actual devil Jesus [ __ ] Christ it
feels like an alien has invaded my body
and the alien hates me for no reason
alright there's a lot to unpack here
estrogen and progesterone not only work
in our reproductive system but they also
have a lot to do with our emotions when
you take oral contraceptive pills you
are giving your body a steady state of
estrogen and progesterone every day
because it's the rise and fall of the
hormones that stimuli relates the
release of the egg from the ovary what
happens though is that instead of having
a cyclical pattern of estrogen and
progesterone you get a constant pattern
of estrogen and progesterone and for
some women that creates emotional
changes at human
555555
asks what does low testosterone even
feel like or look like testosterone is
the hormone in our body that's made in
the gonads both in women and men by the
way it gives you motivation and drive it
also helps you grow your muscles it
helps your mood it helps your bones and
often when people are aging they'll feel
some of the signs of low testosterone
you'll feel tired you can feel depressed
people will feel like they're getting
more fat around the belly these can be
signs of low testosterone or it can be
signs of other things because as you
know these are very common complaints
men have a lot more testosterone than
women and men often are haunted by these
sites that that say oh you need to take
these testosterone pellets because they
will replace your testosterone what ends
up happening is they get dangerously
high levels of testosterone if you think
you have low testosterone you can get it
tested with a simple blood test and make
sure that they're not trying to sell you
testosterone supplements when you may
not need it at Al Hernandez 262 asks
medical question what hormone causes my
body to Crave pizza at 1108 every night
well Al I think it's probably your
cortisol late at night telling you to go
out and get some pizza this is way too
late for your digestion I don't think
most people realize that hormones and
digestion are intimately linked there
are hormones like insulin glp-1 insulin
like growth factor leptin and ghrelin
these hormones literally interact with
the digestive system to tell us when
we're full when we're hungry when we
should eat and what we should do with
the food if you're struggling with
Cravings late in the evening it often
has to do with high stress levels so you
want to fix your sleep schedule at
eco-terrorist asks can hormones really
change your bone structure how are you
going to get wider hips I know it's
crazy hormones are so powerful for
example there's hormones released during
pregnancy that actually relax the
ligaments in your body so you may look
like you have wider hips or you have
looser joints in the case of puberty
when estrogen and progesterone are
released for example in a girl you start
to develop breast tissue and you start
to develop wider hips but it's more
because of the fat redistribution than
changing of the bone structure at JoJo
Glimpse asks why does adrenaline affect
the memory well adrenaline actually
makes your memory stronger for that
moment for example if you're in a very
scary stressful situation you probably
remember that really well adrenaline and
other stress hormones like cortisol and
norepinephrine these are brain and
adrenals this system is meant to keep us
safe in danger so imagine running away
from a tiger that's alerting your brain
and the rest of your body that it's time
to focus on a task at hand and so you're
not going to be able to make complex
decisions like your taxes or whether you
should buy that house during that time
at d y keto watch 4 asks from an
evolution standpoint why do I get sick
when I'm stressed that is so stupid I
know it's a little known fact but when
you're chronically stressed your immune
system can be suppressed but we think
it's because when you are in a stress
State your resources are all sent to the
immediate processes that are going to
help you escape from the danger your
muscles your eyes your your forebrain
that's going to help you escape the
situation gets all the attention and
things like the immune system are
neglected at Harlot princess X asks so
like why does progesterone make Peeps
horny does anyone have the scientific
explanation I'm genuinely curious
actually when women are struggling with
sex drive it's estrogen that gets
replaced to help that this is especially
true around perimenopause and menopause
where the replacement of estrogen will
help with sex drive at Sputnik
v1234 asks does coffee actually lower
some hormone related to mood also coffee
has been shown in a large study of 450
000 people to actually improve
cardiovascular health and extend life we
know that coffee raises your cortisol
levels but cortisol levels are not
always bad in fact cortisol is what
wakes you up in the morning and that's
why drinking coffee kind of makes you
more alert just don't go overboard at
Nouveau vet asks how do we become
insulin resistant so let's talk about
what insulin even is insulin is an
essential hormone this is the pancreas
right here where all the insulin of our
body is created these beta cells in the
pancreas are producing the insulin that
will let the glucose into the cell
glucose is the primary fuel for the
brain and the body you need glucose to
function say I decided right now to
drink a big glass of apple juice you
need to take that blood sugar and put it
into your cell so they can use it for
fuel or energy when they want to get
into the cells they need someone to open
the door for them and that's insulin and
if you have a lot of glucose running
around the insulin just can't catch up
and over time it almost becomes a little
deaf so if you think about it it's like
children screaming all the time and the
parents kind of just get used to it and
become more deaf to it that's kind of
how insulin is when it's seeing a ton of
glucose all the time at Steve M Kemp
asks how does Cortisol affect body fat
levels this is huge the relationship
between stress and body fat is something
we all need to know about so when
cortisol is high it releases glucose
from the cells and when glucose is
hanging around in the bloodstream you
get insulin because insulin lets glucose
into the cells you're basically
signaling to your body to create more
fat cells by letting that glucose in so
cortisol releases the glucose insulin
goes up that's a signal to the brain to
start storing fat at Glen Allen 2010
asks what is hormone replacement therapy
hormone replacement therapy is using
both synthetic and biological hormones
to replace low levels of hormones in the
body every single woman goes through
menopause which is a drop in the hormone
levels so every woman will go through a
phase of life where they will have very
low levels of estrogen and progesterone
whereas men it's more of a gradual
decline women can get hormone
replacement therapy men can get hormone
replacement therapy and transgendered
individuals can get masculizing or
feminizing hormone replacement therapy
so if you're a trans woman you can take
things like estrogen and anti-androgen
therapy so that your hormones can better
match your gender identity with any kind
of medical intervention you should check
with your doctor to check if it's right
for you at Ayo underscore IRL asks why
can hormones make you so irritable so
rude hormone imbalances can feel really
frustrating the week before your period
called the late luteal phase or in the
media is often called PMS premenstrual
syndrome it's a time where estrogen and
progesterone own has dropped that is the
time where you'll often feel more
irritable where you'll feel more
depressed there are other hormones such
as testosterone and hyperthyroidism so
high thyroid hormone these can also make
you feel irritable or angry at DWT shark
asks how do hormones and emotions and
stuff work like how do our bodies just
respond to things it's insane
neurotransmitters and hormones are two
separate systems but they're really one
and there's a lot of overlap so for
example dopamine and serotonin are
considered neurochemicals however they
can create hormonal effects when you
exercise for example there are feel good
neural chemicals and there are certain
hormones like estrogen and progesterone
and testosterone that can go to the
presynaptic area of the neuron and
actually send neurochemical messages so
they're very intertwined in many aspects
add Dr John Ray asks why does a thyroid
have beef with everybody like when it's
in the mood it can just screw up all the
other systems so petty so true right the
thyroid is this tiny little gland it has
effects all over the body it affects
your metabolism your body temperature
hair your nails your skin you might be
feeling symptoms of low thyroid which is
dry skin slow heart rate fatigue and
weight gain hyperthyroid symptoms would
be sweating weight loss palpitations
there is no tea or supplement that will
fix your thyroid problems if you suspect
that you have a thyroid problem please
go to your doctor and get the simple
blood test at shifuni asks when do
hormones go back to normal after
pregnancy asking for a friend you may
see some initial normalization within
weeks but really it takes about six
months to get back to the normal levels
of hormones after a pregnancy at Maggie
Dolce asks why am I so tired and why
won't my brain produce the awake hormone
this is a great question I actually
wrote a book about it called I'm so
effing tired when we're feeling tired
all the time it's usually a sign that
there's something off inside of our
bodies that's creating inflammation
you're tired because your energy
Trifecta is damaged what is the energy
Trifecta It's a combination of gut
health immune health and Hormone Health
the trifecta tells you to be tired
because it's protecting you while you're
healing yourself at atq 662 asks can
taking hormones help you lose weight oh
gosh taking hormones for weight loss is
something that's very popular however
it's not recommended hormones do
hundreds of things in the body for
example people will take thyroid hormone
even though they are not low on thyroid
and what happens is they end up getting
negative side effects like heart
palpitations restlessness panic attacks
hormones are not a One-Shot deal you
don't want to take hormones for weight
loss at boopstagram asks what is hormone
therapy for breast cancer there are
breast cancer tumors that have estrogen
receptors on them you can take a
medication like tamoxifen to block the
estrogen from binding to that receptor
therefore starving that tumor to death
and there's also hormone therapy that
you can use for prostate cancer those
are the two main types of cancers that
you can use hormone therapy for at BLK
his studies asks did you know that Percy
Julian was a Pioneer in the chemical
synthesis of medicinal drugs such as
cortisone steroids and birth control
pills I did know that he is known to be
the father of birth control pills and
also for cortisone for example here's
some synthetic steroid which he created
in a lab that could match the steroids
in the body and so you can inject this
into a human and it will have effects
like steroids in the body it's pretty
amazing at not Vishnu asks how do I
stimulate my pituitary gland to give me
at least two more inches this is such a
popular question in the pituitary gland
in the brain there is a hormone called
human growth hormone which in children
helps them grow in adults it also has
other effects like muscle repair but it
doesn't really help you grow anymore
because your growth plates are fused
unfortunately if you're an adult even if
you add human growth hormone you're not
going to get taller at zinzial sibs asks
I find it wild we have a period every
month until menopause the period stops
but apparently the hormones get worse
hot flashes mood swings weight gain Etc
why perimenopause and menopause is is an
issue that is underdressed and under
treated in most of the population
perimenopause happens almost 10 years
before menopause so people will start to
get symptoms as early as 35 36 and then
it will go all the way up to 50 and last
for a few years during the menopausal
transition that's a lot of years of hot
flashes weight gain mood changes Etc so
I suggest a combination of food
lifestyle sleep Stress Control and
talking to your doctor about whether
hormone replacement therapy might be
right for you so these are all the
questions for today thank you so much
for writing in and starting the
conversation about hormones that needs
to be had thanks for watching hormone
support